being successful doesn't heal your
childhood trauma you know so there's
still stuff inside and that's the thing
you can have the most sparse beautiful
looking zen-like external environment
but on the inside you're still cluttered
you're holding on to toxic relationships
you're maybe holding on to a
soul-sucking job or a path in your life
and if if you're experiencing all that
clutter it prohibits you from being
present with this beautiful Zen space
that you happen to be in and it's kind
of like what Robert persick the guy who
wrote Zen and the Art of Motorcycle
Nathan and said you
the only Zen you're gonna find at the
top of the mountain this is in you bring
up there with you you know so it's like
that every space you enter every
relationship you enter
any accomplishment you have you're going
to bring all the happiness that you're
gonna get from that with you to the
relationship to the space to the
accomplishment